cuando yo era niña había una canción que
me hacía llorar muchísimo escuchaba así
los primeros tonos no tenía que escuchar
la letra y lloraba automáticamente esta
canción es la canción de la muñeca fea
no la han escuchado para los que no lo
han escuchado porque creo que casi ya no
se usa
la canción dice algo como que la muñeca
estaba escondida por los rincones
temerosa que alguien la viera y
platicado con los ratones la pobre
muñeca fea pero había una frase en la
canción que me hacía llorar muchísimo y
es la parte donde la muñeca fea se da
cuenta de que está olvidada o se asume
que está olvidada y empieza a llorar
lágrimas de aserrín
llegó la muñeca la muñeca fea es una
canción escrita en el 63 y hoy una
muñeca llorar a llorar y a lágrimas de
polímeros
y yo pensaba siempre que bueno esa parte
de mí había quedado atrás que yo esta
niña ya no ahora soy una mujer adulta de
casi 38 años
y el otro día me di cuenta que la
canción me sigue haciendo llorar y
llorar a mis casi 38 años
pasa el tiempo entre mi pasión por las
relaciones internacionales la historia
de la geopolítica la ciencia política
los movimientos sociales y mi amor por
la ropa usada o la ropa vieja las cosas
viejas y usadas
habría un lugar cree un lugar que se
llama bravo vientos
es la siguiente imagen por favor es este
pequeño espacio no
solía ser más pequeño pero es pequeño de
pequeño espacio y tiene siete años de
existir y hace poco me di cuenta que ahí
en cuenta de que en realidad lo que hice
en este lugar que es una tienda de ropa
vintage donde todo tiene entre 25 y 100
años de haber sido manufacturado creé un
refugio para todo aquello gracias para
todo aquello
qué es puede ser considerado la muñeca
fea del mundo de la ropa del vestuario e
incluso de los objetos
y se cree un refugio para el olvido para
todos los que nos sentimos olvidados
porque la verdad es que si yo lloraba
con la muñeca fea es porque yo me sentía
olvidada y casi todos los que lloran con
una canción es porque se pueden
relacionar con la canción entonces bueno
cree ese espacio y lo que yo hago es que
busco ropa que tenga como les digo entre
25 y 30 años es lo más representativo
del siglo 20 del mundo occidental tengo
algunas cosas también el mundo oriental
pero la mayoría es mundo occidental y le
investigó y entonces me pongo a platicar
con la prenda y digo a ver de dónde
vienes cómo fuiste hecha cuando naciste
y vi que estaba sucediendo en el mundo y
toda esta investigación que hago no me
la quedo yo la quiero compartir porque
creo que es importante para todos
conocer de dónde viene lo que uso qué
relaciones sociales y políticas hay
detrás de todo aquello que usaron y que
puedo seguir usando y entonces le
escribo estas etiquetas a la ropa
y cuando la gente entra pues no es una
tienda de ropa nada más es como un museo
no necesitas ir a comprar de hecho si
necesito yo dinero para vivir como todos
pero lo a mí me encanta me encanta que
la gente salga de ahí sintiéndose como
que saben más cosas y que además se
sienta contento porque pues ahí todos
estamos rotos de todos somos
maravillosos dudosos bueno esto sucedió
mucha gente me dice de dónde sacas esas
cosas porque eventualmente sin mi fuente
fueran los armarios de mis abuelos que
ya no existen mi negocio se habría
acabado hace rato pero hay muchas
fuentes y la más importante y la más
maravillosa y la que me trajo la
epifanía es esto
entrar a casas de personas que ya no
existen de la forma en la que ustedes y
yo existimos gente que murió
pero de alguna forma está viva en los
recuerdos de sus familiares de las
personas que amaron y entonces
imagínense en la maravilla alguna gente
piensa que es un poco espeluznante pero
para mí es increíble
entro a un espacio tan íntimo no tan
íntimo como son los cajones de la vida
de alguien más el closet del armario el
ropero el cuarto la casa huele entre
polvo y vainilla o el increíble no como
como todos los objetos oxidándose y
entonces estoy ahí en ese en ese espacio
no se ve en este papel tapiz
espectacular estoy ahí viendo los
vestigios de la vida de alguien más
estoy expuesta a la vida de alguien más
tengo permiso más instrucciones
de verdad es maravilloso de solo pensar
eso se me está poniendo la piel chinita
es increíble estar expuesta a eso porque
automáticamente cuando uno está expuesto
en la vida de alguien más a algún
acontecer que parece exterior uno voltea
a ver hacia adentro invariablemente por
eso vemos películas y decimos así yo
haría esto o cuando lees un libro no
cuando un amigo te platica algo tú te
pones en ese lugar aunque la cosa esté
por fuera uno voltea hacia adentro
eso se llama confrontación y gracias a
la confrontación gracias a este proceso
confrontativo que se da en esos espacios
que están vacíos
yo me di cuenta que cuando rescataba
algo en realidad no estaba rescatando
algo me estaba rescatando a mí
estar expuesto
justo a esto que les decía los vestigios
de la vida de alguien más
no es solamente ver la vida de alguien
más es ver la vida de alguien más en un
momento histórico de pronto estoy ahí
sacando un montón de cosas entre fotos
ropa esté cartas postales no diarios y
todo eso lo puedo leer y me doy cuenta
de que hay preguntas que hacer sé que
pasaba en este momento en el mundo
porque la gente se vestía de esa forma
porque si estaban ciertas telas porque
había ciertos cierres porque había
ciertos botones por que la ropa de la
mayoría de los mexicanos en el siglo 20
estaba hecha en méxico lo que
significaba para la gente usar tal cosa
cuál era el modelo de vida que se quería
perseguir
todo eso está en esos vestigios son
vestigios de la vida de alguien pero son
fósiles sociales invariablemente estar
expuesta a eso me hace preguntarme qué
pasó si usted estar expuestos al pasado
de alguien a verlo ahí uno se pregunta
invariablemente qué pasó qué pasó antes
de que yo naciera qué pasó mientras yo
iba naciendo que pasó metros aprendí a
hablar mientras aprendía a comunicarme
con otros les aprendí a escribir metros
y se mis primeras relaciones sociales
que pasaba que pasaba pero lo más
importante
una de las preguntas más importantes es
que si me pregunto qué pasó y qué pasaba
y qué está pasando con mi pasado en el
mundo que estoy haciendo es la
confrontación
por qué
mayor cosa increíble
la vida
para mí
es un textil infinito
uno nace y es arropado por una cobija
que ya existe que fue empezaba a tejer
muchísimos años antes de que ustedes y
yo estuviéramos ni contemplados ni sus
abuelos y bisabuelos o sea desde el
principio del homo sapiens y luego
cuando creamos el lenguaje podemos
escribir la historia desde entonces está
tejiendo se está cobija todos los días
la gente los humanos que estamos vivos
lo estamos tejiendo nuestra cobija
social vamos a decir es y la tejen
personas que conocemos como puede ser
einstein no figuras así lo maticas o
marie curie o los terribles dictadores
que han existido a lo largo de la
historia pero también le da la tejió en
personas que nunca vamos a saber que
existieron y aún así su hilo está ahí la
hebra está ahí entre tejida en esta
cobija que nos cobija pero no es pasivo
nosotros también estamos tejiendo la
esta cobija todos los días
vayamos a ser conocidos o no
emprendedores o no
filósofos o sonámbulos todos estamos
tejiendo esta cobija todos los días con
nuestras experiencias nuestras
decisiones nuestra vida en sociedad
porque somos una construcción que no
termina de edificarse
hay un filósofo que a mí me encanta ya
no existe pero está existiendo en este
momento aquí con nosotros cuando estamos
leyendo y vamos a pronunciarlo marshall
berman filósofo estadounidense tiene una
frase maravillosa
que me hace mucho sentido dedicándome lo
que me dedico pero a cualquiera le puede
dar sentido
venimos de las ruinas pero no estamos
arruinados
y si es que hay dos distintos tipos de
ruinas no como estos a los que yo voy
las ruinas como vestigios de la vida de
alguien más de alguien en particular
pero también están las ruinas que son
los escombros de una nación sobre las
cuales edificamos nuestro presente
en ninguno de los dos casos este tipo de
ruinas significan miseria ni significan
deshecho ni significan tampoco material
inservible por el contrario
y estoy empeñado en que nos demos cuenta
son materiales de construcción
las ruinas son materiales de
construcción estos vestigios son
materias de construcción porque casi
como diría benito juárez casi porque le
cambié la verdad le puse lentamente casi
en los individuos como en las naciones
el presente está construido de ladrillos
del pasado todo nuestro presente el
presente de ustedes la vida de ustedes y
nuestra vida colectiva
aquel humano ser humano individuo o
aquella nación o país que no atienda a
sus ladrillos
a su base sus ladrillos del pasado
tendrá invariablemente un presente es
frágil un presente súper débil
ojalá igualar ese poquito aquí a mi
amigo porque pues si no que padres si
atiendo al pasado si lo rescato me
rescató a mí nos rescató a todos rescató
mi colectividad
pero quién tiene tiempo en esta
posmodernidad para de verdad estar
contemplando que necesita ser rescatado
no se des de rescatar una prenda un
objeto un barrio un edificio una nación
porque justo en la postmodernidad con la
tarde modernidad para algunos autores
vivimos casi casi sin sintiéndonos como
amenazados de caer en este espeluznante
vacío hay un remolino de imágenes
preconcebidas preestablecidas y
construidas en la sociedad que tenemos
que perseguir tenemos que tener esto
tenemos que hacer esto deberíamos vernos
así el deber ser el deber tener el deber
verse bien
nos abruman que no tener tiempo de estar
pensando del rescate no es justamente
para evitar esto para evitar que nos
absorba el remolino espeluznante social
que hemos construido es que necesitamos
dialogar con el pasado de dónde vienen
esos deben ser de dónde vienen esas
imágenes quién les construyó por qué que
estamos persiguiendo todos de dónde
salió ese deseo de perseguir tal cosa
esta cosa que me abruma que me hacen
tienen suficiente de dónde salió
la respuesta la vamos a encontrar el día
o los días o los meses o la vida que no
se nos vaya sentando nos confrontándonos
pensando justamente en eso reflexionando
dialogando con las voces que nos
conformaron que han conformado este
presente
a veces cuando yo no puedo y muchos no
humanos cuando no podemos articular muy
bien un sentimiento una emoción o una
idea
una excelente herramienta es acercarnos
a la etimología porque la etimología es
justamente como los ladrillos del pasado
de una palabra no acercarnos al pasado
de una palabra y rescatar
qué es lo que nos va a suceder si
reflexionamos para no caer en este
remolino para salvarnos del remolino
para otra vez poseer nos y sacarnos de
ese abismo espeluznante los captar es
una palabra maravillosa y super
esperanzadora
ustedes ven re captar bien pues viene de
re captar el en latín significa capturar
no retomar
recoger
rescatar
ver todas mis piezas en el piso
es ver todas mis ruinas en el piso y
tomarlas agacharme y recogerlas y decir
no no estoy arruinado no estoy arruinado
yo ustedes no están arruinados y el país
no está arruinado
sólo tenemos que recogerlos
porque ese es el verdadero rescate
asumir que venimos de las ruinas
que todos tenemos piezas ahí destruidas
la invitación para reflexionar sobre el
pasado no es para vivir en el porque lo
soy yo que vivo 24/7 en el pasado
vistiendo ropa del pasado en un vestido
de los 60s como como y todo en vajillas
usadas por alguien más que no es mi
familia que no conozco y no pasa nada
existe el cloro
me la paso viviendo en el pasado
estudiando el pas mis sueños a veces son
en color sepia en serio no es el real
bueno no es para vivir en el pasado la
idea la invitación de reflexionar sobre
el pasado no es perder al pasado porque
es imposible es para poder vivir bien
conscientemente en el presente
entendiendo cómo se construyó cómo fue
construido muchas veces decimos en la
sociedad oigan lo mejor es dejar atrás y
olvidar no como si además fuese posible
tengo malas noticias no es posible hacer
eso porque primero olvidar no es un acto
o mejor dicho es un acto involuntario
uno no lo puede lograr por decreto y por
otro lado dejar atrás significaría
dejarme a mí mismo atrás porque como ya
vimos estoy conformado de un montón de
pasados y decisiones antes mías entonces
la única forma para que creemos de dejar
de sufrir sería anular me sin dejarme
atrás no no no pero el contrario se
dejará atrás olvidar lo libera yo
entiendo que muchas veces no decimos si
lo tomamos si lo queremos hacer porque
estamos sufriendo estamos en una agonía
estamos en una desolación nos sentimos
angustiados incluso deprimidos tristes
por eso yo no quiero pensar en esta
persona ya no quiero pensar en esto que
me pasó y ojalá no me hubiera pasado la
libertad de este tipo de cosas de
liberarnos del sufrimiento no viene de
negarlo
viene de asumirlo viene de incorporar
rescatar
nos rescata a nosotros por asumir nos
libera justamente
para que queremos estar rescatados y no
vamos a hacer libres
entonces pues los invito a que la
próxima vez amigos que sientan que ser
remolino de cardo modernidad
espeluznante está apunto a tomar los que
tenga un poquito y piensen en el pasado
no reflexionen dialoguen con el pasado
entiéndanlo reflexión en lo analicen lo
incorporen lo hagan lo suyo ahora hacen
lo abracen la historia porque la
historia con quien la abraza no
solamente está abrazando la historia se
está abrazando a sí mismo en realidad
nos estamos abrazando a todos el rescate
de uno es el rescate de todos como
sociedad muchas gracias